how were the crowds there the crowds
were
it was like decently credit i think
right now usg is
really banking off nintendo well because
i think the majority of the park was at
nintendo wall i mean
rightfully it is the newest thing yeah
chilling the [ __ ] out of nintendo stuff
even outside of nintendo world
but i mean when i went there totally
made sense as to why that was the case
because it was i was like
damn this is like completely different
level of upgrade to like any other world
out there i want to go i want to go i
don't know
i want to go as well and i want to go
before the country fully opens up and
you get yeah
you know it's going to be hell when
there's tourists yeah because
you probably enjoyed it because there
was there was no one there because like
imagine it you're in nintendo world he's
like
whoa what secrets can i can i see and
then there's a line for everyone
every single thing and like every single
thing you've got to bump or use yeah we
only have to wait like max 15 minutes
for each ride which is very good for an
amazing just really
the worst thing about me amusement park
are the crowds and the lines yeah right
because like i think they also like
cream i like a good way
i don't that's the british coming out on
youtube i like a good queue i don't like
i don't like my way
i think they also structured it so that
like they were anticipating the massive
amount of lines because like the vr
mario kart for example which is easily
the best ride that they have there well
we
i did vr mario kart with you in
vr is it the same thing completely
different oh really yeah
so vr mario kart in vr park in ikebukuro
used to be in shinjuku yeah was like
you're in like a still cart
and you have the vr goggles on and you
have like the glove on that you can like
use to grab items
yeah but the car would have hydraulics
in it so you would like when you did
forward it would turn
yeah but this time around in nintendo
world the car itself is also moving
so it's like moving on a rail and then
you when you move it does it move
and when you move it it moves and you
have the vr goggles on so that
everything around you now is basically a
whole vr go-kart
vr go-karting essentially yeah that
sounds fun and it's definitely it's
hectic dude
i'm super [ __ ] hectic but like that
obviously that one i think is
gonna be the most popular but i think
they perfectly planned for it as well
because
from the entrance of the you have to
enter bowser's castle to get to it
so like the front of it looks like
bowser's castle right and like the
interior and everything is
completely perfectly modeled after
bowser's castle so you like go up the
stairs and there's a giant bowser statue
and that's all part of the line yeah and
you walk past and it's like all the
mario kart are like trophies
or stacked up in order and like they're
clearly anticipated for there to be a
lot of people so they were like
we gotta make waiting in line
entertaining
at least that's what like disney or it
did so well yeah i don't really like
disney the theming was on point right
yeah
i thought disney's theming was on point
but then nintendo was like let me one up
it's a lot easier right when you have a
smaller contained land yeah
to work with so yeah but i mean i do
want to go i will go at some point
i don't know [ __ ] the only thing that
would one-up that is if they added other
nintendo franchises
yeah and they'll kind of expand because
right now it's only really the mario
universe
yeah if they added like zelda stuff like
kirby stuff
or like any of that i do wonder if this
was like a thing that nintendo
wanted to do or universal was like come
on nintendo we've got a little
i have i have a feeling this is kind of
like a trial and er
if we open up like a fully dedicated
nintendo world where there's like
different worlds for different
franchises we don't want it to
completely [ __ ] up
so let's just like borrow usj for a
second be like can we like test it out
with like
one small segment yeah and if it does
well then maybe down the line
we'll make like an actual full because
they could do a nintendo world
like they actually had like you know
they have enough franchises with the
amount of money they made during the
pandemic especially dude like
yeah they could easily open up their own
world if they wanted to i mean just
think of all the properties they have
i'm like all right well you've got like
everything covered like you can do any
ride
any excuse you know what i mean like
yeah everything's covered
why why haven't they done this already
come on i mean nintendo land from what
the sounds of it
sounds really [ __ ] good and really
fun already so
imagine that one like a full-scale theme
park yeah and uh maybe joey will have an
amusement park that you actually enjoy
yeah right because i mean honestly like
that was probably the most fun i've had
an amusement park ever
what food do they have there oh yeah so
they have uh they have toad's cafeteria
okay what do they sell to its cafeteria
they at toad's cafeteria they sell
the food there was actually pretty
decent not the best
themed food i've had because i've been
to like a lot of like does it look like
mario characters
so one of them was uh this like tiramisu
that was shaped after the like question
block
oh yeah so there's a tiramisu like
question blog there's also like a
mushroom soup but like the container is
actually like
the red mushroom so you like open up the
red mushroom cap and like there's
mushroom soup on the inside
i like that i like it when the thing is
like
the design of the character or whatever
they're trying to do
is not intrusive to the flavor of the
food right it really pisses me off
when they do that [ __ ] at disneyland or
when they like make [ __ ] into like
smiley faces with my food and yeah
yeah yeah listen i don't care about my
food being a smiley face don't [ __ ]
do that i don't want to feel like i'm
too
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
theming i don't want i don't want you to
draw a smiley thing on my steak
it's a [ __ ] steak i mean obviously i
feel obviously like nintendo world was
definitely
aimed more towards like younger children
no it's a lot to me
but i'm adult
that like adults could also easily enjoy
right i mean i [ __ ] enjoyed it my mum
would never buy me the food anyway when
i was a kid so it doesn't matter
she'd bring the food she's like you know
you're not having a theme park food it's
ridiculously expensive connor no way it
was a bit expensive but you know as a
first time experience i think
we had to try it and it was again it's
like it's like cinema popcorn yeah yeah
it wasn't the best experience i've had
at a themed like cafe or anything but
pretty decent i don't know if it's still
there but in the uk and uh like the best
the my favorite theme park they had like
alton towers yeah great one
they had a restaurant that was like i
don't know like eight dollars all you
can eat pizza
oh [ __ ] and i was like yo i'm like yeah
let's go to the theme park what for the
rides no no for the pizza oh you
couldn't eat pizza
bro yeah dude and it was great because
you know you would you could even vote
it all off
while you go to disneyland it's like
would you like a slice of pizza eight
dollars that's the thing man i never
i didn't think i would appreciate it
that much until i was given
all-you-can-eat pizza for like eight
bucks and i was like it wasn't great
pizza
but it was all you can eat yeah i mean
exactly doesn't matter my life was like
this is the best thing pop
[ __ ] the ride stuck the theming all you
can eat pizza
i mean sure if you put that at the theme
park it automatically goes up that's
just because
the establishment
unlimited tiramisu just normal tiramisu
we just got it from somewhere i'm like
okay [ __ ] okay now we're playing okay
fine just give me food it's gonna be
fine just play the mario theme in the
background
i'll feel like it's just something yeah
there's just something so nice when you
go to a theme park and for one minute
they're not trying to rip you off yeah